wir befinden uns mitten in der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft und ich glaube
ich muss niemandem sagen dass dieses
Jahr alles anders ist also es gibt gute
gute wirklich sehr gute Gründe die WM
dieses Jahr nicht zu gucken und
nichtsdestotrotz ist natürlich die
Leistung der Spieler die sich zu dem
Besten ihres Landes hochgespielt haben
und dort teilnehmen nicht zu
vernachlässigen ich möchte aber gar
nicht groß die WM beurteilen sondern
möchte vor allem eine Person die auch an
der Spitze von dem ist was sie macht
heute würdigen nämlich den teamkoch
Anton Schmaus von der Nationalmannschaft
und wie indem ich eines seiner Menüs
heute nach koche ich bin nämlich auf
einen kochboxen Hersteller aufmerksam
geworden Solar heißen sie und die machen
besondere kochboxen es gibt unter
anderem auch eine kochbox vom Restaurant
Ochs und Klee hier aus meiner Stadt Köln
erinnert euch das teuerste Restaurant
meiner Stadt öffnen
und das Menü das wir heute zubereiten
werden heißt das Lieblingsmenü der
deutschen Nationalmannschaft dazu gibt
es noch zwei Bärchen dazu es wird also
ein guter Tag ich hoffe das Video kann
jeder genießen egal ob jetzt die WM
schaut oder nicht ist auf jeden Fall
interessant zu sehen was kocht so ein
mannschaftskoch weil er hat ja nur
Spitzensportler in seinem Team ja das
finden wir heute heraus so kommt die Box
zu euch nach Hause und ich weiß das wird
gerade irgendwie wie eine Kooperation
ist es auch irgendwo aber ich hätte das
Video sowieso gedreht ihr habt mich
darauf aufmerksam gemacht ich habe mir
das Ganze angeschaut und es gibt voll
viele Sachen die eigentlich geil für
Videos sind weshalb ich eh da bestellt
hätte habe aber mit ihm gequatscht und
sogar einen Code für euch bekommt den
verrate ich euch später wir gucken
erstmal in die Box rein
sehr unscheinbar hier haben wir einmal
die Menükarte da sehen wir schon kleinen
Spoiler wie das am Ende aussehen soll
und außerdem haben wir einen Kühlbeutel
ich nehme an auch mit irgendeiner
Kühlflüssigkeit wirklich eine Menge
Sachen die auch zum Teil schon
vorbereitet sind ich würde sagen wir
packen das ganze mal aus und zeigen es
euch in aller Pracht und das sind die
Zutaten für unsere Vorspeise ich habe
uns ja schon mal das mitgelieferte
Bierchen aufmacht die haben Lachs wir
haben Achtung süßkartoffelpüree Kräuter
Mayonnaise eingelegte Zwiebeln Kresse
und ein Limetten Chili Sud denn die
Vorspeise heißt Ceviche und Ceviche ist
natürlich eine Köstlichkeit ich habe
noch nie gegessen noch nie überhaupt
nein also das Besondere ist ja das in
unserem Limetten Chili Sud brauchst
erstmal in unserem Limetten Chili Sud
kocht jetzt quasi der Lachs so ein
bisschen vor sich hin deshalb bedecke
ich den hier und ihr merkt schon es gibt
quasi nichts zu kochen das ist die
Besonderheit guck mal wir können jetzt
vielleicht sogar dabei zuschauen wieder
jetzt ein bisschen Garten
und das krasse ist das hat nicht
irgendwie ein Team von volar oder sowas
gekocht sondern das Team von Anton
Schmauß genau ist echt krasser also das
echte Restaurantteam bereitet das da mit
teilweise sogar oder vielleicht sogar
immer bei den in der Küche vor und packt
es ein relativ kleinen teilig so dass
man halt alles separat hat man sieht
wirklich schon wie das sich so leicht
verändert oder 16 interessant so lassen
wir es einfach ein bisschen stehen steht
da wie lange fünf Minuten fünf Minuten
Timer 5 Minuten ab jetzt und dann
richten Timer auf 5 Minuten ihr merkt
ich koche heute eigentlich nicht also
man muss nicht kochen können um das zu
Hause zu machen was man aber machen kann
ist diesen QR Code scannen wir werden
das gerade auch mal getestet das Meter
da kriegt man immer das gesamte Menü
angezeigt willkommen bei Anton Schmaus
Nationalmannschaft klassisch Hinweise
zum Menü drei Gänge für zwei Personen
Vorspeise dann sieht man noch mal wie
man das ganze anrichten soll
Hauptgerichte her super easy also ich
bin positiv überrascht mach das zum
ersten Mal ja vielleicht bei sturmwaffel
schon mal solche Videos gesehen ich
verlinke euch auch noch mal seinen Kanal
weil der hat auch die ein oder andere
kochbox auch von Star dürfen schon
getestet vielleicht mache ich in die
Richtung auch noch mal was ja das geht
vor sich hin wenn es bereit ist richten
wir an
[Musik]
hier haben wir also die Vorspeise 5
Minuten Arbeit wenn man es überhaupt
Arbeit nennen kann wir müssen nur noch
probieren und das machen wir jetzt auch
so wie es in einem edlen Restaurant auch
tun würden probieren wir die einzelnen
Bestandteile weil im Prinzip kommt das
ja aus dem edlen Restaurant wir haben
als erstes einmal diese Süßkartoffel
Creme die eine ganz tolle Konsistenz hat
ich finde das wirklich verrückt ne das
wurde in dieser Küche gekocht und ich
stelle es jetzt in meiner Küche zusammen
süßkartoffelpüree
crazy das Möhre drin schmeckt das so
nach Sterne Gastro es wurde glaube ich
so 18 mal durch einen Sieg passiert so
das ist so diese perfekte cremige
Konsistenz hat die hat es die schmeckt
man schon geil
weißt du also es hat so Möhre
kartoffelle leichte Würze drin Schärfe
lecker auf jeden Fall Kräuter mal
probiere ich auch mal so genau
frisch tolle frische gib mir meine Ecke
vom Lachs süßkartoffelpüree Kräuter
Mayonnaise das ist also die angebliche
Lieblings Vorspeise der Nationalspieler
gesund ist es glaube ich auf jeden Fall
aber wie schmeckt das Ganze zusammen
probieren
was spielt wirklich perfekt zusammen der
Lachs ist butterzart so Sashimi Lachs
hat es eigentlich auf den Punkt
getroffen so wie man es von dort kennt
also der zerfällt quasi im Mund dazu
dieses samtige Püree die Zwiebeln die
eingelegt sind bringen auch ganz viel
mit diese Mayonnaise ist es wirklich
köstlich ich lasse mir das auf jeden
Fall schmecken und ich sage euch so viel
das ist so in der Form dass man sowas
geiles zu Hause ist und selbst macht
auch für mich absolut neu und es geht
weiter mit dem Mittagessen hier ist
Wasser dass ich aufkochen lassen habe
hier haben wir einmal Gnocchi und hier
haben wir eine fertige Sucuk Soße es ist
jetzt wirklich bescheuert passt da ins
Wasserbad Soße ins Wasserbad und jetzt
abwarten wie lange 15 Minuten so 15
Minuten sind vergangen ich hole mal
unsere beiden Tüten aus dem Wasserbad
und es ist schon so richtig schön weich
da drin gehen wir einfach mal so wie sie
sind hier hinein ich habe noch nie sowas
in der Art gegessen
das ist irgendwie so das macht so keinen
Sinn aber es macht Sinn dass die
Nationalmannschaft das mag ist ja ich
meine Nationalmannschaft ist auch
Multikulti so gesehen Schau vor die
durften so verschiedenen Zutaten so
ankreuzen sie die so mögen und der Anton
Schmaus hat dann so ein Gericht oder ein
Menü daraus gezaubert wer weiß
vielleicht werden wir in Zukunft auch
mal mit einem Nationalspieler was
zusammen drehen können und dann können
wir auch die ein oder andere Fragen zu
Ernährung stellen wir geben jetzt die
Soße drüber gefühlt viel Soße für wenig
Nudeln ich meine das macht ja auch eine
gute Pasta aus ne ja das stimmt einmal
durchrühren das ganze ich habe richtig
Lust drauf ne dave ist gekommen zum
probieren wir haben vor uns die Pasta es
ist wirklich bescheuert weil ich habe
einfach so zwei Beutel warm gemacht und
zusammengeschüttet also ich habe gar
nicht gekocht deshalb wenn du jemanden
loben möchtest wenn es gut schmeckt lobe
nicht mich es riecht schon mal sehr gut
das riecht schon Kraft ne und die Nudeln
sehen so speziell aus
weiß was daran wieder geil ist dass du
einfach ist ja nicht zu Fans Sie nicht
zu viele Facetten schmeckt einfach gut
und einfach kein Wunder dass unsere
Jungs das so gerne mögen oder
saftig ist es auch also no joke das Ding
ist dieses Menü werden nach vorne schon
so celice und so auch so ein bisschen
ausgefallen und zwar kann halt jeder
machen und zu kochen das finde ich cool
wer hätte das gedacht es wird nicht
schwerer es steht 2 Minuten dauert das
Dessert wir probieren es jetzt aus in
vier Punkten weil sogar das wird
beschrieben soll man dieses Avocado muss
anspritzen auf dem Teller ein Avocado
Bananenmus mit Kokos und Bananen Chips
ich glaube auch die Augen die könnte man
noch besser ja
ich finde der ist sehr schön das sieht
aus wie damit das hier nicht so komisch
aussieht einfach mal den hier
Passionsfrucht Chutney in die
Zwischenräume Bananenchips
sind alles so schöne Kreationen oder wir
müssen mal so ein Crashkurs zu machen ja
wie macht man so einen Teller schön ich
glaube man kann aus allem einen schönen
Teller machen und das sind ja auch so
Sachen die lernst du natürlich wenn du
eine Kochausbildung machst ne hier haben
wir unser Dessert zwei Minuten waren auf
jeden Fall nicht ganz verkehrt ich
probiere das und ich bin mir eigentlich
relativ sicher dass es nicht schlecht
wird
okay wir probieren das ganze aber was
euch bestimmt auch interessieren wie
viel kostet der Spaß drei Gänge die ihr
gesehen habt für zwei Personen Kosten 49
€ mit dem Code Max könnt ihr 15 % sparen
sind 41 € und ein paar zerquetsche ich
finde das echt fair also drei Gänge nach
Hause geliefert mit so einer coolen
Story kann man eigentlich nichts sagen
es war auch alles super lecker probieren
wir ein bisschen von dem Mousse bisschen
von der passionsfruchtcreme
auch wieder diesen
spitzensportansatz weil es ist halt
einfach clean so Avocado Banane
Passionsfrucht mit Sicherheit auch so
schmeckt auch mit Sicherheit auch nicht
wahnsinnig viel raffinierter Zucker oder
so der hinzugefügt ist nur das ist Essen
mit dem es einem auch nicht schlecht
geht so ne das kannst Du essen geile
Komposition
und vor allem wirklich eine kranke
experience beim Kochen und anrichten
weil es ist so man kann nichts falsch
machen und hat Spaß am Ende was Hübsches
auf dem Teller ich hoffe ihr hattet Spaß
an dem Video ich auf jeden Fall wenn
euch das gefallen hat freue ich mich
sehr darüber denn wie gesagt es gibt
auch noch von anderen interessanten
Persönlichkeiten und Köchen kochbox
würde falls ich das Video gefallen hat
könnt ihr gerne einen like da lassen
auch ein Abo auf dem Kanal und hier
drüben ist dann für dich vorgeschlagen
ist Video guck gerne rein ich darf
schmecken bis zum nächsten Mal bye bye
bye
[Musik]